[Music]
imagine if every time you went to a
restaurant they made you sample all the
things you ate the last time you were
there
not new versions of those things the
actual things they went to the waste
plant found the remains of your meal and
made you re-eat it after you'd already
processed it and taken what you needed
welcome to previously on segments
this mountain is never seen or heard
from again in this episode i'm beginning
to think marvel uses these establishing
shots for atmosphere only
dragon swoops towards the palace actual
footage of the game of thrones season 8
writer's room somehow makes it into this
[Music]
episode
that's it just the toys what about the
people she knew the other countless ways
she's impacted this universe's timeline
i know there's talk about erasing entire
realities but why is it leaving the
marble behind when the toys disappear
of the many things this show yadda
yaddas for the sake of our belief
staying suspended i'm tiring the most of
this resetting nonsense
i really wish someone would get this
burnout bureaucrat a drink so he can
stop mean mugging everyone
we see ravona and mobius taiwan on later
in the episode he knows what's going on
he's probably just angry he was never
invited who are these people are they
members of the tva and why do they do
nothing to stop this escape
maybe they're just concerned citizens of
the null time zone i'm gonna say we have
a florist a tax attorney and the owner
of a small but delightful deli here
so why on their day off are they
choosing to watch these dull ass court
proceedings instead of making me my
pastrami on rye
next case
next case right here the tva court
procedures apparently follow the same
rules as marco polo the tvs technology
is absurdly easy to use or maybe our
technology is absurdly difficult
point is these tin pads don't even
require an access pin or a fingerprint i
get a new tv remote and i have to study
it for hours just to change the input
select
but sure program yourself a functional
time door in mere seconds on a device
you've never seen before
child look there's only one explanation
for indoor fog that thick and it's not
supernatural
there's a reason the time keepers keep
asking for more funyuns is all i'm
saying
look i know there's protocol she could
have information mobius has been at this
for a while but doesn't seem to notice
how paper-thin their so-called protocols
are
other than vendetta's pruning and
paperwork their adherence to rules is
about as strict as a dress code at
burning man
what how i'm a simple man give me owen
wilson saying
wow or how and i'm taking a sin off
all i really want is for him to star is
a farmer turned stock trader so he can
take his
cow and sound from plow to dao
is that too much to ask this shot is
stunningly beautiful and all but there
are a
bunch of meteorites belting the area
sure we're in a resignation moment here
but survival instinct is strong and
there's a tube to hide in right there
if i had paid more attention in physics
i'd be able to explain to you why two
massive celestial objects this close
together should be wreaking
way more havoc than this calm scene
would suggest i'm sure it goes something
like magnetic fields blah blah gravity
blah blah seismic activity blah blah why
is this lake so calm
do you think that what makes a loki a
loki
is the fact that we're destined to lose
no according to this show what makes a
loki a loki is the british accent
loki's can be anything as long as they
sound like they're from london
despite the inescapability of the time
twister displacement collar things
sylvie loki and the hunters all go along
with this dramatic hallway struggle walk
also why are they even in the hallway
right now the tim pads can open a glowy
door anywhere why not bring them right
into the time theater
a bad memory prison how quaint
lady siff is a dick to loki
lady siff is a dick to loki's
lady sif is addict to loki because loki
was addicted to lady siff and now loki's
likely won't stiff because ladies if was
a dick to loki's
also honestly any testicular trauma
after the second loop is on you loki
tuck your low globes away the second sif
walks out i've seen rupaul's drag race i
know there are ways
work your low-key and figure out what
caused that spike
j-o-i two variants of the same
being especially you forming this kind
of
sick twisted romantic relationship sick
twisted aren't we supposed to love
ourselves people spend millions of
dollars searching for this kind of
therapeutical breakthrough
kip bent mobius but only in a way that
turns and reconnects to itself so it
ends up with only one true side and a
single boundary curve
science jokes how to box your ears damn
going from spirited argument to ear
punches is in no way a healthy
progression
mobius really needs to use some of his
pto if you could go
anywhere anytime where would it be
i can go anywhere anytime mobius would
be excellent at tv sins
z20 variant all these questions what are
you getting at
at this point we all suspect ravona is
hiding something but that doesn't make
it any less absurd to be irritated when
someone whose job it is to investigate
things has questions
you've been spending too much time with
loki's yeah i definitely have been
spending too much time with low keys
tvson staff meetings
i'm glad we're back at good old roxcar
because i've got something to say
this is a terrible name for a store sure
with it being low she's hideout it's a
fun play on women having two x
chromosomes and the little logo
looks like two people but i'm just
saying the second you throw another
consecutive x in your store name and
only sell regular toys flashlights or
plugs
you're gonna have some very disappointed
walk-ins i'm willing to accept a lot
about this little device
okay that's not true i've pretty much
sinned every aspect of it by this point
but if you thought i was gonna stand by
and let you participate in blatant zoom
in enhancing on my watch well you can
just plan a kiss on my sacred timeline
i've heard it once i've had a thousand
times i know right so why aren't you
exploring
walk around look for flaws you're a loki
for odin's sake so you've been misted
loki i know would have solved this room
and beyond a riven by now so i just have
to trust the word of two loki's
how about the word of a friend why does
this resonate with mobius he may believe
that loki is not entirely lying but i
feel like the show has spent a lot of
time establishing so much distrust
between these two characters that a
friendship at this stage is very
unlikely
i mean i could see this blossoming into
a friendship like after solving a few
cases together mobius eventually invites
him over to have dinner with the family
and mobius realizes that loki might be
crazy but he means well and then they go
and cover a drug smuggling ring operated
by a former cia paramilitary unit who
then kidnaps mobius's daughter
forcing the two of them to go on a
rescue mission which gets foiled and
they're taken to the baddies hideout and
tortured but they escaped to have to
return to mobius house because the
baddies are going after his family now
but they get there just in time and the
whole thing ends dramatically when loki
fights the main batty in the rain
now that's a relationship i would
believe oh wait are helmets
optional now or is this guy just an
anti-helmeter and people are so
tired of his bull they've lost the will
to argue about it anymore
that's what i'm like to do just riding
around on my jet ski
prune him holy sh i mean you know marvel
can bring anyone back and i know marvel
can bring anyone back but
loki doesn't know that this moment is
surprising shocking and hiddleston sells
it so well i'm feeling my own feelings
but also jet skis also also ravona
doesn't prune loki here because we all
know you can't prune a loki without
filling out the proper forms
and completing the prerequisite boss
battle tom hiddleston looking good in a
shirt and tie cliche
i've lost track of the number of times
i've been killed so go ahead
do your worst look has only actually
died once in the mcu and he fake died
twice
hardly enough times to lose count and
since the one real time and one of the
fake times it wasn't even this
particular low key
it'd be a little weird if he couldn't
count to one
[Music]
sure why not why wouldn't someone just
be able to approach unhindered not only
hijack the chrono callers but unlock
them both with one push of a button
they use text making i got a deuce tex
machina i guess
these two guards were apparently trained
to not ever under any circumstance
attack the assailant at the same time
then who created the tva
the disney imagineers duh
oh please just because the camera didn't
hear or see ravana doesn't mean neither
of the two people in the room would have
heard her get up and approach
do you know how hard it is to sneak up
on two people in an echoey room
especially two loki's
marvel didn't think we could mourn
another loki death for more than two
minutes they were probably right but
whether it's their fault or ours
it's still a sin also the possibility of
this loki gator being the leader of this
group tempted me to remove
all the sins from the episode and then
promptly reapply them because i feel
toyed with but instead i'll just give
the standard single sin for taking full
four episodes to go full loki verse
the universe wants to break free so it
manifests chaos
i'm an agent of chaos we get hit all the
time by rocks and meteors
some of them the size of cars some no
bigger than your hand
you had rings around them you're amazing
wow you're so dominant
your father would have been proud of you
jen timekeepers are watching mobius
always
always watching fine you want the truth
you can't handle the truth you can be
whoever whatever you want to be even
someone good
i like being bad and then going home and
being good